something has happened to zits for
Generations big Pharma sold pimples as a
stigma to be controlled and concealed
but recently the 12 billion dollar
blemish Market began promoting its
treatments not using models with perfect
complexions but by showing the reality
of acne vulgaris this shift was
championed by The gloriously Confident
Hydro stars from starface starface is
not merely the breakout face of gen Z
acne it is the Exemplar of a novel trend
of disruptive brands that Target gen Z
with a jarring visual ascetic and an
authentic emotional appeal such brands
are dorkly awkward and Adora be real in
other words adorkable
dockables are instantly identifiable by
how they vandalize the visual Conformity
of Boomer Brands and millennial blands
the adorkable look is a Lo-Fi high camp
Snapchat Tick Tock K-pop 8-bit ascetic
that Revels in mismatch fonts jarring
colors and Norm core photography its
tone of voice is Arch ironic meme Laden
and disarmingly Frank and giving gen Z's
shopping habits adorkables tend to
Cluster around Beauty fashion self-care
and snack foods but what really defines
an adorkable is the direction of its
gaze whereas traditional Brands offer
self-validation to the aspiringly
self-confident adorkables offer
self-expression to a generation torn
between self-consciousness and
self-promotion gen Z lives an in-app
life glued to the phones that impel them
to consume comment and create a push me
pull you of shopping and sharing that
baffles many Boomers indeed to
Generations weaned on branding's
aspirational Elegance a dockables
discomforting as Bob Dylan going
electric yet this discomfort is not a
bug but feature if you don't get or like
a Docker balls you're not the target one
parallel is the anti-loitering device
mosquito which blasts a vexatious
ultrasonic tone Audible and irksome only
to those under 25. adorkables do
something similar with the visual
Spectrum but to lure a generation that
sees very differently but while the
dockables may be radical they're far
from revolutionary adorkables don't want
to smash the system they simply wish to
repackage it for a quirky new generation
and so many mainstream companies are now
stumbling to mimic a dockable memes and
ape the adorkable voice
but if by appealing to gen Z's
authenticity and vulnerability these
Brands succeed in challenging a status
quo that for example stigmatize acne for
Generations then consumers of every age
will be richer for adorkables I'm Ben
shot The Branding and advertising
Economist for Bloomberg opinion
[Music]